it's sort of like if you look at what
are our what do our rich friends do now
that's not common and then that's just
going to become like like more people
are going to do that thing
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what's going on so did you see uh andrew
huberman replying to my tweet
yeah i did
i feel like kind of giddy a little bit i
feel a little honored
yeah do you feel like it's kind of cool
to interact with him right
uh yeah i think he's great i just really
i think he's really great uh like the
cool part about this podcast is that we
me and you get to hang out often and
then once in a while like there's a
bunch of guests i would say for all the
guests i like them all but maybe
two out of every 10
i'm like oh this is a this person you
know they're my kind of people i just
really get along with them and i really
respect what they're doing and he's
definitely one of those people so hear
me out
i think that we should get okay so you
have to go somewhere on wednesday and so
i went and found a guest tell me what
you think about this guest and then when
i got this person i was real i realized
we should do this way often way more so
i met this guy
and he has his business that's like a
fine local services business in in
california and i go what did you used to
do and he goes i was in the cia i go
what did you do there and he said i
would go to the middle east and i would
try to commit peop get people to commit
treason and i would do it by trying to
influence them and persuade them and
basically give me secrets so i can uh
you know we could do espionage and i was
like that's the most amazing thing i've
ever heard can you tell me everything
and i just sat down for like an hour and
i asked some questions
and i asked him to come in the podcast
through the podcast or that was pre-pod
pre-pod and so i i go dude you just want
to come out and tell me all these he
like told me stories about being in like
an alley in lebanon trying to get some
person to show up and he the way that he
convinced he's got all these like weird
stories and and and it's about
persuasion and influence and and i
realized i'm like sean and i should just
start doing that way more just getting
people who are like interested in
regardless if it has to do with money or
not
yeah yeah i think that's cool
i met a guy once who he was like using
our product
and we held a meet up and like i think
200 people flew to our office and
there's a big party basically
and uh this guy he was like
he was always very mysterious because
our product was kind of like clubhouse
so you could just kind of sit there hang
out all day just chat
it was always online
and i was like oh so you like don't work
or what's the deal like you're always
online doing this
he's like oh yeah i'm like in between
you know gigs and i was like i'm
unemployed i didn't really think too
much of it but when he showed up i was
like i noticed two things one is the guy
was incredibly muscular like you know i
kind of like bumped into him and it was
like i hit a rock and i was like oh that
was so strange but he wasn't trying to
look super fit but i could tell it's
like you know those people that like
yeah they could do 90 000 pull-ups it's
like oh your core is just incredibly
you're just your whole body's made of
muscle um it's not that you have giant
muscles but your whole body is a muscle
and um
so it's like okay that's interesting
noted and then later on in the night he
um like i introduced him to two people
one person was from russia he spoke
russian with them i introduced another
person from pakistan and he spoke like
urdu with them and i was like how many
languages do you speak was he a white
guy
white guy and i was like and he spoke
with like almost like a perfect accent
and i was like what the hell
why do you know how to speak in all
these different languages he's like oh
um and he kind of like as the night got
on like you know he wasn't drinking but
we were all drinking and he's like
he kind of confided he was like yeah i
was actually a spy for many years
and he starts telling me these stories
and they're so unbelievable that i'm
like
i just kind of think this guy is he
lying is he telling the truth it's very
hard to tell because the stories are so
good like you know the story is like you
know he's in a bar in russia
and you know this mobster's there and
then yuri milner the famous investor
comes in and he's like okay i want to
talk to yuri
and yuri just kind of blows them off and
he says something in russian and this is
like the perfect one-liner and i was
like what's going on here so we go to
the battery later that night the battery
is basically this private members club
in san francisco that is like a soho
house for san francisco
and my the previous investor who
bankrolled my whole company the idea lab
that i was working at he created the
battery so we go we're hanging out there
and on the way out it's like two in the
morning we're leaving
and the battery has i think 14 hotel
rooms but really there's like the
penthouse that you rent out for parties
and the penthouse i think was like
10 grand a night at least maybe 15 grand
a night to rent out um
and there's an elevator that goes
straight up to the penthouse and so at
that elevator we're walking out and at
the elevator is elon musk he's getting
in the elevator and it's him
it's jason calacanis
and there's two other people we don't
know
and uh and i was just like you know kind
of like fan girl mom was like oh
that's elon musk
and so the guy the spy guy he's with me
and he goes oh elonzer he goes hold on
he walks over and they're waiting for
the elevator the elevator is about to be
there he walks straight up to them and
he goes
like classic pickup artist doesn't
address elon he goes jason
he's like jason and he goes to jason
calacanis jason is like oh hey uh what
what's up
he's like jason um i met you last year
at the conference and i told you you
know what what i do with the government
all that um
and i offered you a tour i i offered you
a tour but i forgot to give you my
number um let me give you my number now
and i'll be able to get you that tour
and if uh if if elon wants to come he
can come too oh my god
he's like he's like he like focused on
jay's cat guys it was just sort of like
uh you know elon if you're interested
you're welcome to join as well you could
tag along and then he walked away and i
was just laughing because it wasn't like
some super it's like he tried to do a
super smooth move
wasn't that smooth in my opinion but it
was still hilarious and he had the balls
to approach so you know good for him so
who was the guy
i mean i don't want to say his name but
yeah he's just a guy and i like haven't
seen him since
that was my one night with the cia guy
well this guy's coming on uh when you're
gone and long story short we should do
more cool like that
yeah for sure speaking of cool can
you i don't know what's going on with
this constitutional and i know you
know everything about it can you tell me
because it's actually amazing or like
yes
i got a dm a few days ago and said hey
a group of us are getting together to
buy the constitution
okay like like like the united states
constitution the united states
constitutes i think there's um 11 of
them right
11 copies i think there's only one
that's in the hands of private buyers
this is the one who owns it um
so i don't know who owns it but it's
being auctioned off by sotheby's so they
said hey there's a sotheby's auction in
a couple days
we're gonna create a dao which is a
crypto term for basically like a group
just a group of people think of it like
a company um
we're gonna form a dow and everything
anybody could contribute contribute any
amount you want and we're going to try
to buy the constitution and i was like
what the and i was like you know i
was like that's great um
i was like how much is it you know how
and i think he said they're gonna need i
want to say
10 or 20 million dollars i think it's 20
million dollars that they're going to
need to raise who messaged you
um i mean i don't think they all want
their like name out there necessarily
okay well who's the organizer behind
this
it's a gr it's a small group of kind of
like nft collectors
okay it's not packy or
no he's kind of so they they basically
approach me and i think some others
to try to help get the word out so the
the amazing thing is so there's a thing
called the created constitution dao
and um and they have raised in three
days i think
three million dollars from two thousand
people something like that so i'll just
pull up the twitter handle so the
twitter handle is constitution down and
it says we the people for the people
we're buying we're buying the
constitution
um from sotheby's in four days we need
your help and then if you go to the
website
that shows that they have uh it says
amazing copy at the top what if we held
hands and bought the constitution
together
it was just a hilarious way of putting
it and then it says uh they've raised
3.6 million dollars so far
and i think they need where do they
write their target um
okay i don't think they write their
target anywhere here uh but i i'm pretty
sure i i asked the guy i'm pretty sure
they said they need like
roughly 10 to 20 million dollars that's
crazy
it's actually pretty amazing so who who
how does it work who owns it and who and
how is it tracked and how do you know to
trust these people the way this would
work is
a group of people get together they buy
a thing now this is how they've bought
several other things so they bought uh
people are creating dows to buy crypto
punks so oh you want a crypto punk but a
punk cost like a million dollars now
you don't have a million dollars well
you want to put you want to invest 10 10
000 into a crypto point cool so we can
all pull together 10 000 each and buy a
crypto punk collectively for a million
dollars and we all own whatever that
math comes out to as you know we don't
do public math something like whatever
you know less than one percent of the
crypto punk is yours and you can sell
your stake in the crypto point so they
fractionally own it so that's what i
think they're trying to do here is
they're trying to fractionally own
uh the constitution
which is a hillary they're going to turn
the con they could take the actual
constitution they're going to turn it
into an nft
and then you can fractionally own the
nft and what laws or loose understanding
of it how does it protect the investors
how are the investors protected
um protected in what way what do you
need protection from who's that to get
you um they can lie about the price that
they sold it they can never sell it they
can uh who so okay we're buying it if
they get a hold of it then they can
accidentally custodied i don't know how
they do custody so like i don't know who
actually holds the keys maybe it's a
group that owns the keys i think the way
the dow is structured is there's a
wallet the wallet holds the nft and it
requires x percent vote in order to
do anything with it to move the nft
again um so you kind of vote as a group
and if whatever over 50 of people do it
then um
then then they're gonna do okay hold on
let me tell you what this person said
um
so okay maybe i could say his name it
says it in his profile so this guy
austin kane reached out he goes
um we're
he just he started off hot we are
literally purchasing the constitution of
the united states
okay
i go cool how much is it
uh sotheby's estimate is around 15 to 20
million we're building around the clock
your the nft we did shaped his views on
this idea so i'd love to have you be a
part of it blah blah and they're
basically pulling together assets i
think the discord group that they have
has like thousands of members like i
think they had 10 million in soft
commitments like verbal commitments and
3 point something million actually
funded
commitments and so
uh you crowdfund the dow um and then i
think they what they plan to do is they
actually plan to hold the physical
constitution in like the smithsonian or
something like that um so they they plan
to like have have
do they make a profit does this guy
austin make a profit
for organizing
um i don't know they don't you know
there's not a ton of details and about
the how the dao is structured and
whether they have like some preferential
thing and you know by the way so this is
the same dude
they got 10 million in three days
10 million they're soft commitments they
have 3.6 actually wired into their
wallet and you're going to say we had
this for the jordan thing and yeah uh
looking like i was talking to a friend
about that the other day i'm like i
still think that would be great the only
reason
like if we ever actually wanted to do
this i think there's the difference is
is that that that constitution is likely
just being sold to the highest bidder
whereas if jordan found out that someone
was gonna do xyz he'd be like no
that i don't want to do that yeah
yeah perhaps perhaps uh then again it's
been on the market for what seven ten
years something like that so maybe maybe
he's ready to sell if somebody can
actually
uh you know meet the price i think one
challenge we had was a we're just busy
and just kind of around saying
it somebody would actually have to go
boots on the ground figure out yeah go
see it go figure out why it's not
selling figure out what the you know the
the rules are around could people airbnb
it or could you turn it into a museum or
could you do something with it or is it
literally going to be an inactive asset
um you know but i think this is
something that can happen there's
another version of this have you heard
of kraus house
no what's that so i'm a little jealous i
didn't think of this idea myself but i
might just i might just do my own the
name is really good kraus house so kraus
house which is k-r-a-u-s
uh house
um
it might be the weird spelling of house
too but basically they're uh it's
crosshouse.club
and here's what it says we're a dow of
basketball fans
and we're crazy enough that we're gonna
try to buy an nba team and so they're
basically trying to do the same thing
they're trying to crowdfund and buy an
nba team today nba teams are owned by
billionaires you know successful
business people steve ballmer types who
go buy these teams for one to two
billion dollars
and the idea here is why don't why
wouldn't all the fans of let's say you
know like the die-hard crazy fans of
you know the grizzlies or whatever the
like uh why wouldn't they band together
could they band together could they
raise enough money um between fans of
the team and investors who just would
love to own a piece of an mba team and
you buy the team and then you you
control the team through the same sort
of vote so you decide which gm do we
hire do we keep this person on for
another year or not and so it's sort of
like a crowd controlled nba team which
is you can't
that's a yeah it's a dope idea it's
incredibly it's impossible because with
buying a basketball team uh or any
american sports mage like one of the top
four or five sports
it's impossible to buy or not impossible
the the issue is not the lack of money
the issue is that it's like you know in
england they knight you and they start
calling you sir richard branson in
america we allow you to buy a sports
team like it's a select group of people
and very few people are actually allowed
to do it and it's done that way on
purpose so for all the people that's
like true you basically you have to get
approved by the other 30 owners so um
you know they can vote to block you but
it's not to say they would vote to block
this like i think this could generate a
ton of uh attention and press and be
seen as pretty forward thinking i don't
think it's a given that they would block
this um i don't think it's a given that
they block it but my point is is this is
not like a thing like oh i'll just get
the money and buy it i'll just go and
buy it right
yeah but i do think money is the
limiting factor here because uh if you
go like there's a team that's for sale
right now
and if you want to buy them you have to
go put up the you know sort of like you
i think you need to come over the top
with the bid so you're not going to get
a deal here you'd have to say
okay you know the price is 2 billion
we're going to play 2 billion or we're
going to pay 2.4 we're going to play 3
billion because
we have to be the winning bidder and if
you could choose between a simple clean
transaction with another billionaire
you'd probably take that so we're going
to have to like
buy something that's got hair on the
deal now there's another group that's
doing this in a much more uh practical
way
and i don't know if practical is better
so what they're trying to do is they're
they have a dow and they're trying to
buy a like fourth tier
um soccer team and like the english
premier league or whatever so there's
like not a not a team that's i don't
know how soccer works but it's like not
the actual premier league but it's like
you know there's the ranking system
where you can like ladder in or you can
get demoted out so they're buying one at
the bottom
and that's like a no it's you know the
show ted lasso they're basically trying
to do ted lasso so they're buying this
like joke of a team who did that and
they're like great
it's another group of people another
another crypto group uh that's putting
this together and they're they're buying
the team they're gonna oh and that they
can do that's a pretty permissionless
thing and the price is like not you
don't need two billion dollars to do it
you can buy it for 10 million dollars
and so you're gonna buy this team for 10
million bucks they're gonna crowd
control the whole thing they're gonna
min nfts because they're gonna own the
ip of the team brand and they're gonna
they're trying to be like they're trying
to show what uh
technology kind of like first crypto
first team how they would run their team
as an example that other bigger teams
might be able to like look at and say oh
that's smart how they are they meant to
they sold 20 million dollars of nfts for
their team and every jersey comes with
an nft how does that work um or well you
know there's a social token that gets
you access for season tickets like what
does that mean and so they're trying to
demonstrate it that way and they're
trying to literally rank up and the goal
is to eventually get into the premier
league and be you know can they one day
go play against manchester united or
whatever um that would be the dream i
don't want to spend much time talking
about nfts and crypto because i'm so
bored of it but
i just read this amazing wall street
journal article about gary vaynerchuk
did you happen to see that i didn't see
that but uh i've been following kind of
what he's been doing but tell me what
stood out to you gary's if for the
listeners gary's been on the pod a ton
if you everyone probably knows who he is
if you don't know he's basically he's a
celebrity for having a big mouth but
he's like cool and he's and he talked
but he talks a lot and he owns an agency
that at this point is quite large if i
had a bet i would say they're like a 200
million revenue business like it's
really big and he bootstrapped it and
he is on fire lately so basically before
we get to the article lately he launched
a thing with michael rubin where um
i forget michael rubin launched two new
businesses and gary's a partner in one
of them i think it's the like nft
trading card one is that it yeah
you told me about this yeah yes and then
he also is doing he has a new book
coming out and he just launched this
thing like a year ago we had him on when
he did it called v friends which i think
it's like a
collection of nfts i think it's valued
north of 500 million dollars right
uh i'll have to look up the latest but
yeah it was basically like a top 10 top
15 it's been a top 10 top 15
um crypto project for
its entirety basically and i talked to
him like the day at launch or something
like that um i was with him at this
dinner and i think he said that he had
made like 20 or 30 million dollars that
day from it like just a huge sum of
money there's been 93 million dollars of
sales of v friends and i think he gets
you know let's say at 10 to 10 to 15
stake a royalty on every sale
um so i think it's pretty easy to
estimate at the i think at the low end
he's made 10 million dollars off of v
friends at the high end it could be like
30 million so he's just like prolific
let's say what it does he he decided to
make a a nft token that he could own it
and it guaranteed you one utility just
the way we did the nft that said you get
five minutes of air time on our pod
someday by the way the guy who bought it
reached out okay what do you say he's an
interesting guy doing interesting things
and so you know he wants i asked him i
said do you want to cash that in or
you're gonna hold
and uh he hasn't replied yet
the um
uh garyvee did one where he said if you
own wait is the buyer at my conference
is the buyer just a rich guy is just
like a rich crypto guy
i think he's yeah i think he's like
crypto rich basically not like mega mega
rich not like crypto billionaire rich i
don't think um but just like a wealthy
crypto guy who's yeah like got in
early-ish and has done very well and is
now in doing a bunch of things
so
anyways gary vee's his nft if you bought
it great you have this nft which might
be cool as an nft you might like the art
it might be might he might launch more
products into it someday but at the very
minimum it gave you access to his
conference so it was a conference ticket
in a way for uh that you could use and
it was only i think the only way to get
into the conference maybe so that's what
he did and he hasn't even i think he
just announced when the conference is to
happen and it's going to happen for a
guaranteed three years or something yeah
so kobe kind of bumped it back but
whatever so kind of cool so his latest
thing he's got this new book it's called
12 something 12
things to be a good leader something
like that i forget and he had a rule
that or he created this thing where if
you bought 12 copies of the book you
would receive a mystery nft
it's still to be determined what that
nft or uh and token actually like what
does that actually get you
but he that's what he promised and so
far as of today it is the largest
pre-order ever
in
in publishing history he has uh i think
as of yesterday he has sold one million
copies of his book before
it's even gone live and the people have
no idea uh
you know what what they're getting the
way that he did it was he last night or
a few days ago he did a three hour live
youtube and instagram thing where he
told people to buy the book um and his
whole stick is basically like i don't
ask for much and i provide a ton of
content when i have a book come out i'm
begging everyone to buy it so that's
kind of cool and that's what he did
and it's the largest book release ever
and that is nuts that is so crazy
so
uh the way you and you know why people
are buying this right you know why
people are buying 12 copies of this book
because oh did i not say the 12th copy
they get one of these tokens right they
get they get a mystery nft
so he promised you that there's going to
be an nft it's going to be good
and it's going to be for anybody who
buys i think
i don't know if there's tears or what
but like you know 12 or more
uh books you're going to be able to get
one and so um
and so so it's kind of crazy right like
that's and one million books is an
insane number of books to sell very few
books do a million a million copies i
think
um i was looking at this site because i
i signed up to write a book next year
with uh tucker max's thing
and i was like okay so what's like good
you know it's good like a hundred
thousand copies ten thousand cop no i
bet it's like a thousand
they're like
like you know some stat 99 point
whatever percent don't sell a thousand
won't even sell a thousand copies ten
thousand copies it's like you know yes
the best sellers do eventually
sell you know like a hundred thousand
copies and then there's things like you
know like
four-hour work week or in this category
at least atomic habits i think atomic
habits he did three million copies sold
in the first two years or something like
that and the biggest winner of the past
five years is mark manson's book
which one was that the subtle art of not
giving a that book was so big that
when i was reading the uh quarterly
reports for
who whatever it's owned by harper's
which is owned by
one of rubert murdoch's companies i
don't know if it's fox or news corp but
anyway they like one of their big things
was talking about that book and how it's
like saved their publishing business
right
uh and there's basically so so why did
this work so uh one reason why it worked
is because gary's been doing this for
you know he's been building trust for
like 20 years uh you know like i've
known about garyvee for 10 years and i
you know he didn't start then i don't
think so definitely before that so he's
built up a lot of trust and he's like
maniacal about content production like
he he creates so much content
in addition to everything else he does
um and it helps right the content helps
feed the agency it helps feed all the
things he helps sell books but like the
amount of content he produces is wild so
he built up this trust
he was talking about nfts he's talking
about trading cards before trading cards
had their huge run-up so if you're like
oh gary's time about trading cards i
don't know about that i'm gonna i'm
gonna hold off and see how it goes
then you just see this huge run up in
basketball cards
then garyvee starts talking about
pokemon and um then he starts talking
about nfts pokemon goes up through the
roof nfts go up through the roof and
then you look at his tracker you say oh
man he kind of was also big on social
media
before social media was obvious he was
saying you know
i remember when instagram got bought he
went on the news and everybody's like
underpriced he was like this is this is
a steal and everybody else thought oh my
god they paid a billion dollars it has
zero dollars in revenue like what are
they doing and he was like are you
joking like this is a this is this
absolute steal by facebook he was
talking about musically and music how
people were making how kids were making
music videos before musically turned
into tik tok
and i remember tons of people making fun
of them like okay you know great yeah
yeah 12 we're all going to be like 12
year olds making dance videos in our
bedrooms he was right so he's right on
social media he's right on baseball uh
on trading cards he was right on pokemon
then he was right on nfts he started
talking about nfts and if he's had this
huge bull run
partly because he a guy of his stature
him and logan paul when they started
talking about pokemon they started
talking about nfts it actually drove a
lot of attention into nfts a lot of
adoption
so um
then he launches his own and you're like
oh do i want to buy this v friends this
doodle that he made
it's priced at two and a half eth
so he auctioned off the initial ones at
two and a half eighth
uh today the floor price meaning the
minimum you could the lowest price you
can buy it for is 8.1 so if you just
bought if you just bought hit
uh that's like do eight times roughly
four grand so you know 32 32 000. um so
basically
you you're up almost 4x
on you're up 3x basically on the last
thing he told you about so this time
when he says hey
buy my book i'm going to get you a
special nft you might have missed v
friends you missed the nfts when i told
you about them you missed you know the
basketball cards before they they all
got hot
get this one right and i think if you
have a track record of being early and
right this kind of like fomo builds and
people just start to trust you and i
think that's what's happening right here
is people are like all right cool i'm in
i'll do this
yeah and i think what i would like to do
is i i don't know this but eventually i
would like to do it is i want to look at
what he's been wrong about so gary is
right a lot but he takes a ton of shots
and i was reading glass door reviews of
vaynermedia to understand like what's
what's cool about working there why
people like it so much uh and they were
saying like
the the haters of which they're always
be haters where it was like the negative
reviews said something like
he's always saying the latest and
greatest thing is going to be the next
big thing for example and then they
named like four apps and i'm like oh i'm
not even like these are dead those are
cool like two years ago
and so i'd be curious what what he's
been wrong about but i do think that
that he's likely right more than he's
wrong and he's been right in big ways
yeah um i was actually watching so he
did another cool thing actually not to
make this the kind of the garyvee hour
but um
he did an interview with mark zuckerberg
which i thought was a pretty big deal
amazing amazing it was so good yeah he
was good dude steamrolled sucked too
he kept interrupting him which the
comments were just ripping him for he
steamrolled mark zuckerberg
yeah he somebody said in the comments
they go
uh gary's talking to mark about social
like he's his big brother and mark's
little brother but you know obviously
mark's like we're like invented social
networking and like runs runs the world
um but it was true he really was kind of
like all over him he's a better talker
than mark right so it's actually kind of
natural he's a better um speaker he's
more engaging and he has he's quicker
off the cuff and mark is a little bit
more you know rehearsed and kind of
thoughtful about his words that
doesn't always play super well you know
in front of a camera but uh what did you
think of that interview did you hear
anything that yeah i thought it was
great i thought gary said something cool
about how he's like i knew nfts were
going to be big because of farmville and
how people would pay for these badges
and then he also referenced another
facebook app that i didn't i don't know
what it was but my contacts clues were
like okay it was like a thing where you
could like purchase a cool picture and
he was like that's how i knew it was
going to be big and mark goes you know i
never really thought of that
and i thought that was funny i thought
that was pretty cool also mark's haircut
was horrible as if they just like put a
ball on his head and just cut the bangs
around it
what's he doing with a bad haircut like
that it's all actually gary had a great
line in that which he's like he's like
basically mark's talking about like the
the the metaverse you're gonna have this
this avatar you're gonna have like your
character who has its own virtual
clothing and it wears that like it looks
like a sim basically if you ever played
the sims and he's like you've been
living this life like basically like
mark already looks like a sim like mark
looks more like a character from a video
game than an actual human being he talks
more like a character a video game than
a human being and he wears the same
exact thing every day on purpose
which is what your character in a video
game does like black shirt
blue pants and he said any and he nagged
him but
he didn't go into details but he was he
was kind of like complimentary
like you've been ahead of the curve but
i thought it was hilarious
um you know that he caught him on that
in a way um all right let me ask you a
quick question so i've been thinking
about this something i've been thinking
about we've had a bunch of friends talk
about screen time limiting screen time
and i've been thinking about this so i
just did a very short amount of research
so basically
uh i was curious about what trends have
existed where rich that separated rich
people from poor people for example um
in in the greek and roman era which
actually i don't know what
years those were actually um bc
sometimes bc uh basically the you were
rich if you were uh very very white and
roman poetry would praise the white girl
and that meant like the the pale and
paleness was yeah it was a was a mark of
beauty and um
of social class and things like that
because basically you're not outside
working really hard of course uh that
changed and in the 1960s like uh
it kind of started right around that
time where being tan meant that you have
leisure you know you have enough time to
go hang out outside and have fun and
skin tone became kind of a marker of
wealth and and during world war ii women
were using tea bags as self
self tanner coco chanel around uh the
the 1930s 1940s talked about uh being
bronze and being tan and so now it's
like became popular b-tan so what do you
think
and i'll tell you what i think mine is
what do you think in like 20 30 50 100
years
is gonna be that thing my opinion is
what it's gonna be is a lack of screen
time so not like like it's gonna be like
oh you
use a computer no i don't know i don't
usually yeah i think it's gonna be
people and so like uh mark laurie talked
about that i believe jack dorsey talked
about that elon musk has mentioned it
bill gates says his kids don't get
screen time that's what he said yeah he
said this a few years ago this came out
i think he kind of backed off because it
sounds really bad because like dude you
addicted the whole earth to social media
and you're like don't let your kids do
it but let me see what the the exact
thing is but i remember for sure
um that he either limited or um or said
you know
uh
said he wouldn't do it so dude i noticed
that once i kind of got a little bit
more success in my career like i don't
check anything on the weekends and like
some for like different projects like
i'll get to it when i get to it like i'm
just not going to check my email uh i i
don't want to be on the screen yeah i
remember it was a big deal when he said
i think his kids were like under three
at the time so it was like uh you're
probably not doing a ton it was like my
daughter's two she has a ton of screen
time but like you know i get mark
zuckerberg doesn't have to do that
necessarily so he he was like yeah maybe
when they get older as they get older
i'm sure they will but uh but people
were like hey you know the people the
media sort of out to get you you know in
this kind of case i've got i've got a
couple like
pretty wealthy friends and they'll be
like yeah like our kid has never like we
don't use our phone in front of them um
we don't let them see a phone and then i
you know i'll go and hang out with other
friends who maybe aren't in that
position and like we go out to dinner
and they're playing on the phone the
whole time and so that's my prayer i
think it's already happening and i think
it's going to happen the next 20 30
years there's a few more so there's
actually um
there's actually uh you know other ones
so i think back in the day being fatter
so having a big belly used to be a sign
of wealth yeah
because obviously you had enough like
means to to eat food and you were you
had a leisurely lifestyle
and now it's the exact opposite right so
like um
you know having you know abs is more
seen as a higher status thing than
having a belly uh somebody you said i
have a big nose people used to tell
somebody told me once like oh back in
the day that was like a sign of like
great power and authority or something
like that
i don't know if that one really could
change over time because you can't
really control it as much i guess nose
jobs but but i think you're absolutely
right that these things shift over time
that the
status signals that you have shift and
it's basically you want to be doing what
the masses are not doing
so um you know if everybody's on
horseback you want to be in a car when
everybody's on in a car you want to go
learn horseback riding um that sort of
thing same thing with like hunting like
you know uh having others hunt for you
and then now it's like a status symbol
in a way to be able to have the free
time and the skill to be able to go out
and um go out and go hunting like have a
hobby have a hobby like that
i think that um i think you're
absolutely right that
being away from like the digital
experience like how like being able to
not have to either work online play
online or talk to people online it's
going to be
a status like it's definitely like a
status symbol because it's going to be
so rare it's going to be rare more rare
than whatever you know a diamond or gold
or anything like that is because
everybody is going to be completely
engrossed as we already are halfway
there in like kind of like the online
world so having anything in the offline
world is going to be like a extreme
luxury
and that actually like if in terms of
like money making and business that
actually like is an interesting trend to
look at um there's this thing called the
uh what's the dumb phone thing is it
called a light phone
um i keep hearing a lot of people talk
about this thing have you heard of the
light phone i i don't know much about
getting it so basically if you haven't
seen it the light phone is a really
minimalistic looking phone looks pretty
cool honestly uh looks very clean design
it's like a very basic phone that
doesn't look like an app it looks like
it's all remember remember zune or
microsoft it looks like the early cell
phones but just like cleaner and um you
know like a flip phone or whatever and
basically it's just a phone that doesn't
have apps so you can text on it you
could call on it but you can't use the
internet beyond that and um it's meant
to be like hey do you want to like
you don't want to be detached from the
world maybe your kids or whatever like
uh you know as you
you know if you need to be reached for
an emergency but uh but you don't want
to be kind of like on instagram you know
at the time i think it's a great idea
the problem with it is kind of
inconvenience with it which is like i
think you need to like
you need to be like switch your sim card
every time you want to use it and
like that if you want to use the same
phone number so that's kind of annoying
but um but i think it's great and i'm
surprised this isn't bigger i think it
was like a kickstarter project uh i'll
buy it i'm going to buy it so we just
did this nft thing and we said we'll do
content stuff i'm going to set us up
with the or i'll set it up and you can
decide you want to go with the health
thing with that executive checkup and
then i'll i'll buy one of these uh light
phones and we could talk about it i
think it's amazing i think it's cool you
can still use music i think it's really
cool
yeah i think it's great and what else
comes to mind that's like this uh so
what are some other things so there's
obviously in-person experiences so
travel
meetings concerts i think that already
kind of has like a bit of a premium but
i think that'll get extended the premium
will get larger the the rarity will get
will get higher on on that because
if most meetings just happen over zoom
then you'll it'll be a special meeting
when you make an effort to go fly and
meet somebody face to face um same thing
with a concert if you're you know going
there and being there and experiencing
it it's going to be one of those
feelings you can really only get by
doing that so it's going to become more
valuable over time like i was talking to
a comedian and he said like he's like
dude i was worried like you know after
covid what would happen he's like
demand is roaring back he's like the
demand now for shows is higher than it
was pre pandemic
and so you're asking what else is like
this uh well the rich people poor people
think what else could be kind of a
status symbol i think i have a couple
yeah i think like the splitting time
thing between cities um it's still
expensive but it's one place it's still
expensive but it's not prohibitively
expensive um so like i think that that's
gonna be uh far more com i'm doing it
now and i realize i'm like in a
fortunate situation but i think that
it's far more uh accommodating than ever
before
uh so i think that like that part-time
living in in splitting time between
cities is going to be quite common um
i don't know what else yeah i think
that's a great that's actually a great
one uh it's sort of like if you look at
what are
what do our rich friends do now
that's not common and then that's just
gonna become like like more people are
gonna do that thing so like you know
like you're talking about having a few
either airbnbs or like having three
homes and just shift like throughout the
year just shifting based on where you
want to be in whatever season you want
to be in and not having like a hometown
um dude here's some more of a thing
here's one and you're getting into it
now i've been into it for a minute as
well which is did you see this
well kinda i tweeted out asking people
to see to say like what what like i so
i'm i'm building this house um and i'm
like how would you optimize it for
longevity health and fitness and i got
so many amazing replies and the most
consistent one was cold plunge and sauna
so many people are interested in that
and i think that that's a much bigger
trend than i ever thought so i think
having home saunas and in home cold tubs
that is something that's going to be
that's i think we're still in the early
stages of that i never would have
thought that that was going to be a
thing uh yeah that's the
i just bought a sauna by the way like
two days ago i know i saw you
what's his name andrew said like don't
do infrared and you're like uh but i
bought an infrared is that so okay yeah
uh by the way there's a sick company so
check this out is it uh david david's
company
florence have you seen this this guy
just dm'd me who i'm friends with he
spoke at hustle again he goes hey i just
met with sean about my sauna business
and i and he said this guy yeah and he
said that you also like this type of
stuff have you um did you go look at it
did you see it that's sick uh he just
said he he dm'd me a video and you want
to explain what it was so basically
uh uh floor so there's two that that got
um
that got uh
they got kind of like highlighted here
um
where are you at the url is we are
florins um
how do you spell florins uh
f-l-o-r-e-n-s f-l-o-r-e-n-s
okay
um okay so basically we are florins uh
so basically what he's done is he's
built a in a custom kind of like new
version of an in-home sauna it plugs
into a normal normal outlet which when i
was looking up saunas that was like one
big thing it's like you have to i don't
have to get an electrician out here to
handle the power of the sauna it's like
small enough where it fits in uh it's
like a great like
like it's like made for like you know
one person it could fit easily then
there's a super nice like super clean
design so like most saunas kind of look
like this kind of same cabin looking
feel this looks like it fits in like a
modern home it's like very slick looking
um and so he's building this thing and
he showed me one he's got it i'm gonna
go visit him he's got one down here not
too far from where i live
uh so then there's one then there's one
in the presidio called ancient ritual
have you seen this one that's the one i
saw ancient ritual so and so there's two
so ancient rituals the other one that
people are kind of hyping up and i think
that one is like almost like peloton for
asana so you get in normally when you
get into a sauna you're like on your own
it's like dude here go sit in this this
hot box and like think or you know talk
to the naked guy next to you like i
don't know like do whatever you want to
do
i think what ancient i don't know
exactly what ancient rituals doing but i
think what they're doing is it's sort of
like a guided meditations they have
sounds they have scents they have like
um they'll talk you through like what to
what to like it's like it's like calm or
like headspace like meets a sauna uh
that's my like prediction they're a
little bit they're very stealthy there's
like nothing on the website but that's
my understanding of it just from uh
figuring it out dude the florence thing
is amazing
yeah so i'm really excited about both of
these i don't think either of these is
like you know mega huge business
but i think it's i think it could
definitely be a really healthy business
um and it might be one of those that
surprises you maybe there's bigger
demand maybe this is maybe this ends up
like pools right like
i think um our buddies are in the they
bought a pool construction company who's
telling me something like you know um
like some absurd percentage of homes
like uh 50 of homes or whatever in in
areas that can host a pool like will get
a pool in the suburbs and um
and it's like a it's
that's not the exact percentage it's
like it's a 50 000 average ticket
um it's the number one like kind of like
optional upgrade to a house that that
happens and um
and so you know those companies are
doing really well pool construction
companies and so maybe
if you fast forward 10 years down the
road sauna and cold plunge is going to
be as common as swimming pool is in
america like i could i could see a world
where that's the case
i definitely could too so um i'll have
to remember exactly what these the the
study says but there's a there was a
very reputable and famous study and it
said two interesting things the first
thing that it said was if you sauna for
two 20-minute sessions a week
it decreases the likelihood of
cardiovascular disease by something like
30 or 40 percent a massive number
then it said if you sauna for three
20-minute sessions
a week it's gonna decrease it by like 60
like it's like the the numbers are like
astronomical just from two to three let
alone zero to two and so sauna's like i
i i the what the way it works is
basically like when your body heats up
that much
i guess it stresses it and that that's a
really healthy and good stress and uh
anyway it's pretty sick i'm all about
that do you want to talk about these
last two things you have on here i'm
very eager what those are yeah let's
talk about them by the way just to put
an end point on this um like we talked
about this because just we're interested
in it and like whatever it's just this
is our hangout if you want to be able to
on the wall great but i would also say
there's been a big lesson i've learned
that is anytime people
live anytime you discover a group of
people who are very interested in and
living a lifestyle that is different
than yours it's very easy initially to
write it off and just say oh that's
frivolous that's um that's just kind of
like whatever you know they're out of
touch or
uh they're weird or whatever like it
doesn't really matter what what category
it is like when i when i saw gamers and
people who stream video games and watch
other people playing video games it was
so strange to me i remember making fun
of this kid in college
because i walked in on him and he was
watching somebody else play a video game
on a live stream and the guy was playing
in korea and i was like you're watching
a dude in korea play this video game why
don't you just play better yet why don't
you get outside and like let's go go get
some food and i made fun of him for and
then years later i'm like selling my
company to twitch and like i'm i'm like
talking about how great this trend is
and he's like called me he's like you
motherfu you know like i dude you made
fun of me for this 10 years ago and here
you are now like now you're on board and
that's happened to me so many times in
life that now i go the exact opposite
way i see somebody like you who says the
same thing that our other buddy said
which is maybe i should go to the mayo
clinic and get these advanced scans done
once a year i think huh maybe that's
something more people are going to want
to do why would he want to do this why
are people choosing plant-based
lifestyles what is that all about you
know like and so now i lean in any time
i discover these things and that's
become some of the best a like either
like discoveries life changes i can make
or b investments it's a great way to
invest because you're actually on the
like the cutting edge of stuff you're in
early which is super important obviously
there's a book on like a famous business
book on it where he talks i think it's
crossing the chasm or something where he
talks about like early adopters and then
like the there's basically this like
bell curve of people where it's like
in the beginning of the curve it's like
late people who are late to it and then
like the middles like the average joe
and there's like early adopters and
there's one more like cutting edge and
you and i both have like a handful of
friends of which i would actually say
that i i forget the names of them but in
that bell curve there's people who are
getting names because you got the idea
right but you uh like butchered all the
names so it's basically
the earliest is innovators and it's like
the people actually like figuring things
out and then there's early adopters then
there's early majority that's the kind
of like big chunk late majority that's
the other part of the big chunk and then
there's the laggards who are like you
know people who still have aol email
addresses and like you know
are looking driving around looking for
blockbusters and for a lot of things i
would say you are on the right side
you're uh either an innovator or the one
next to it an early adopter
and i'm trying to go i'm intent i'm
intentionally trying to go that way so i
thought
uh you know i'm just not that i'm not
like a futurist type of guy because i've
been so wrong
and i figured out the formula for it the
formula for it is um have an ego
make a prediction
be wrong like five times and have it
rubbed in your face how wrong you were
boom you're not you're now a futurist uh
like i remember the first time the
iphone came out and i was like who the
wants to like read tiny text on a
screen like that's awful i was like
nobody's watch a movie on this i was
like yeah you can watch who would ever
watch a movie on this like tiny square
like that's like that would be the worst
it's worse than an airplane headrest
like i remember saying these things to
people and you know like i was in
college i was like a junior in college
there's nobody remembers this but i
remember being that wrong snapchat i
remember being that wrong my username
still has the word test in it because i
was so certain
i was like snapchat this is this is
stupid right this is just for kids and
dick pics and stuff like that like
certainly won't go on beyond this
bitcoin i was wrong early on right like
guys in my office tell me about it back
in 2012 2013 and i was kind of laughing
and saying guys let's focus on something
like legit here and now i'm like you
know a bitcoin evangelist and so
like twitch same thing i was wrong about
streaming i've been wrong so many times
that i've actually flipped the script
now i kind of had to reassess my life
and say
i'm not going to be very good as a
technology entrepreneur or technology
investor if i just continue to write off
the big things as dumb and
stupid early on like i need to go the
exact opposite way okay what would it
take for me to do that and i just i just
inverted so instead of you know anytime
i see that the same feeling i instead
lean into curiosity what's making people
want to do this
when i think it's so strange and now
that's that's like flipped the script
for me and we either had justin or emmet
on at hustle con or on here and they
were talking about justin tv which was
the site before twitch became a thing
and it was basically uh anyone could log
in and create their own live tv channel
and
emmett i believe you could tell me if
i'm wrong i believe the story was like
emmett but like there's a small corner
of the site where these like guys were
watching video games and it wasn't a lot
of people like thousands of people but
they were spending two percent i think
of the traffic um
at that time but they were spending a
significant amount of time watching and
he was like that's this is the one that
we got to go to and i don't even think
it was that as data-driven actually the
data pointed against it because again it
remember it was a small trap it was a
small amount they had a combination of
two things working their favor
number one emmett was like i guess
actually the number one factor was
they were the current thing
wasn't working and they had like no like
they had nothing to lose they don't they
were gonna run out of money and fail or
they had to try something dramatically
different and um when you feel like
you're and you have nothing to
lose you actually have the one of the
greatest assets on your side um which is
that you know when you have nothing to
lose you play completely differently
than when you feel like you have
something to lose so that was the first
thing they had to change they the things
that were popular were all like uh
illegal streams it's legal streams of
sports so they knew
oh people want to watch this but we
can't ever build a business around this
yeah so what 90 of people are doing on
this site we can't use the two percent
thing worked and then the other one was
he was like i personally like watching
these so he's like
i'm gonna go with that
like these are my favorite things to
watch on the network so if i'm gonna
work on this i'm gonna work on the ones
that i personally find you know the most
interesting and actually most of the
company wanted to go work on the hotter
sexier idea which was called uh what was
the thing called the video thing they
had not vidi their their their version
of that called social camp social cam so
the company split in half they said all
right justin tv is not gonna work
abandon ship and we gotta figure out you
know what's the what's the emergency
ship and so
they had this i think michael seibel who
now runs y combinator and justin khan
they wanted to do social cam it was
instagram for video instagram is the
hottest startup in silicon valley but
it's photos we're gonna do instagram for
video
and they were able to instantly raise
money they got tons of initial hype and
traction and press and all the talented
people in the company wanted to go work
there so i talked to this guy jacob
who's the
og designer at twitch and he's still
there he's still at the company today
and i said uh how'd you know like to bet
on twitch instead of social cam he goes
oh no dude i wanted to be on social cam
they were just like nah like we don't
like uh team's full bro like you go work
on on the thing with emmett because emma
is his childhood friend he said you
gotta go to that one he's like oh
all right whatever
you know so like that was what seemed
like the great idea but actually
what emmett did which was leaned into
this really weird behavior unique
lifestyle that these gamers were doing
where they were streaming themselves
playing for eight hours a day that
turned out to be the thing and that's
kind of my point which is like i think
that there's like these i do it on
online communities particularly reddit
but you can right now you could do it on
twitter or you could just type in like
any idea or any hobby and type in the
word forum and you could just find like
these niche communities of people that
are kind of freaks
and it's fun to like learn all about it
like for example
intermittent fasting fasting is now like
we all talk about it um i remember like
eight years ago i remember business
insider wrote an article about like a
microsoft executive and they mocked him
for the like intermittent fasting what
is this
and uh but there's there's been
communities online where i've like read
about people doing this for forever and
you're like fasting like no like
breakfast is the most important meal of
the day just look at anything they make
fun of silicon valley for at the
beginning of coronavirus like vcs are so
paranoid about the real world that
they're wearing masked conferences guess
what everybody's doing now wearing masks
right
oh my god intermittent fasting silicon
valley's latest craze not eating till
noon every day you know what a google
what google engineers are doing right
it's like making media loves to make fun
of it guess what that's what everybody's
going to be doing um you know what are
some other things that are like that i
think you know some of them are
meditation by the way was like that too
uh people made fun of it and then you
know boom it's like the new yoga
uh the other ones i think that that are
happening are like stem cell or any like
blood platelet spinning stuff where it's
like oh you have knee pain well these
guys they like go to puerto rico and
like go to germany and like get this
blood spinning treatment and go
get stem cells injected on their knees
that and uh now they feel good and gene
editing i think is gene editing is one
another one uh breathwork i think breath
work is where meditation was i invested
in this thing called other ships they
just actually launched their app i use
it every single day
and um like i use it religiously because
it makes you feel so good and to to the
average person like i do it outside now
after uberman was like get get some
light on your eyes first thing in the
morning so i do it outdoors um and i'm
sitting in my driveway basically doing
it and neighbors are walking by they're
walking their dog what they feel is a
very normal behavior go go for a morning
walk and they see me like doing
breathing techniques on my driveway and
they think i'm a nut uh and i love it i
go louder as soon as somebody walks by
because i want them to know they live
next to somebody from the future dude
there's this guy his name was bill uh
we'll
there's this guy named arthur leonard
he's uh he's dead now but in the 60s and
70s he was a new zealand track and field
coach and he had runners like paul
walker uh or not paul walker uh that's
john walker uh peter
yeah yeah peter snell and all these like
new zealand guys who started winning the
olympics in the 1500 meters 5k and 10k
and everyone's like dude what are you
doing with your runners and he goes we
run like 120 miles a week we do long
distance running and we go slow and we
just do it just a shitload of it and
this one coach from oregon got really
interested and uh his name was bill
bowerman and he goes well i'm the track
and field coach at oregon university i
have all these great runners what are
you doing and he goes over to in the
1970s in new zealand and he learns from
arthur leonard and he comes back and he
starts making it popular and two things
happen
university oregon gets really good at
track and field and he ends up um
making shoes for his runners so they can
run a little bit faster and he calls it
nike he calls that company nike he
starts it with a with another runner
phil knight
and the other thing that happens and
this just it worked out perfectly is he
starts talking about it to all of his
friends he even writes a book about it
and i believe it's called like the joy
of jogging and the idea of jogging it
wasn't even like a thing in the 70s
people like what do you mean you're just
going to run like art is it
what yeah like aren't the police gonna
go after you and and like like it was
like astounding like prior to the 1970s
right so there was a it was a jogging
craze of the 70s prior to that people
didn't go out and run that just like
wasn't like a thing and so anyway that's
like another example where like running
became popular and bowerman created nike
to kind of capitalize on it
let's wrap up with this last thing here
what's what is this
i always enjoy your wisdom put
yourself out there announce what you're
trying to do and how you're trying to do
it so this actually came from the
facebook uh the zuckerberg interview
with garyvee so garyvee goes you changed
your name to meta you change the name
company's name to meadows like you know
like what's that about you kind of
wanted to like
announce this to what's kind of like the
thinking behind that because i i think i
get it but you know explain it and zuck
basically said this thing he goes
um
he goes you
know i think this is really important
and he goes
you know how it is when you run a
company because you have you know
hundreds of employees thousands of
places we have thousands tens of
thousands of employees
it's really hard to get the message out
inside your own company one of the best
ways to get your company to realize
you're serious about something is to go
talk about it externally so that's the
first thing he said and i thought that
was so true when whenever a statement
gets made publicly inside the company
they also read that article they read
that press and say i guess we are
committed to this i guess we are i guess
that is a top level priority and they
start to take it seriously so all of a
sudden the product managers start
adding features for that thing or the
top talent will switch to that division
because they know that that's an area
for growth for the company so it works
internally then he goes
the other thing is he's like you know we
um
we wanted to put a message out there to
the world like he goes i think it's
really powerful he goes we wanted to say
what we were doing so that people who
want that to exist will come work for
facebook and gary goes yeah it's like a
recruiting thing right he goes
he goes yeah he goes it's kind of
amazing you know
if you just say what you're trying to do
and how you go about doing it
that like it repels he goes you get a
lot of hate
and he's like we always get hate anytime
we announce anything we get hate um he's
like so that's gonna come anyways and
he's like when you say what you're
trying to do what you're trying to build
uh you know what you're trying to do
with your life and basically how you're
trying to go about it you will
repel the people who find that
off-putting and you will attract the
people who want it and he said it so
simply this is not a
oh i've never thought of that or wow
that's such a new concept it's not that
but it reminded me of like a lot of good
things that have happened in my life
that simply came
from saying
what the hell i'm trying to do
why i'm doing it why i'm so excited
about doing it and how i'm planning to
go about it here's what i plan to do
because the other thing facebook
announced was we're investing 10 billion
dollars into you know the metaverse uh
this year like into our ar vr projects
and 10 billion is like a huge number and
so
that basically says we're changing the
name and we're investing 10 billion
dollars that means
this is our future this is the bet and
um and so that will attract talent now i
just thought
that's such a powerful concept for
anybody it doesn't even really matter
what the what the stakes are like i've
done this when i try to hire interns
most people want to try to hire interns
they spend all their time you know
they'll they'll write a blog they'll
write a job post and then they'll like
you know hope and pray the right person
comes by
and the better way to do it is you write
a job post that would attract the you
think about who the ideal person for
this is and you say what would make them
stop what they're doing and be like holy
i gotta check this out i gotta go
reach out i gotta talk to them and so
now you're not going to write a normal
job description that says the role the
responsibilities the requirements
minimum
you also need to know who you don't want
to work there exactly and
it'll work out so like i put a thing up
on twitter once i remember i think i've
talked about this before on here i put
up people on you people on me
uh they present me for everything i do
this one this one was i kind of like
almost hand wrote it and made it look
handwritten and i said hiring an intern
i said you're gonna get three years of
experience in the next 12 months
i don't drink coffee so you'll never
have to go fetch me some
you're not going to know what to do i'm
going to throw you in the deep end but
don't worry don't don't worry i won't
let you drown
and i said you're going to work on this
this and this for me because i'm trying
to do x i don't know i still want what
the startup was at the time is i'm
trying to build x and i want somebody
who can come in and do things like a b
and c and who knows what else
um and i basically was like you know
whatever and there's a ps at the end and
this got like hundreds of applicants to
come in why just because i didn't write
a normal job description secondly
because i said it i said what the hell
i'm trying to do and it attracted the
type of people who
who want to do something like that with
their life you know they found they
found an overlap between their interests
it sounds again so simple but
if you kind of check yourself you say
have i done that when's the last time i
put a stake in the ground i put a flag
in the ground and said here's like i'm
sampar here's what i'm doing
so that you would attract like-minded
people i think you kind of did it with
the fitness influencer thing to be
honest you go
i'm going to do it i'm going to get away
from this business stuff and i'm going
to focus on being i'm going to become a
fitness influencer i'm half joking but
i'm also half serious and um and then
you started posting the content every
day
and you started like doing it in public
on facebook you post on twitter you post
it and i'm sure some people make fun of
you or some people leave kind of
comments that are like slight jabs or
whatever um but like you put it out
there and i'm betting your dms are full
of people who are now yeah it's sending
you cool equipment ideas yeah flying out
to meet you like that's just what
happens when you do that when i when i
tell people someone was like do you want
to make money off this i was like no but
like i would love like a professional
athlete to think that this is kind of
cool and be like oh i didn't know you
like fitness you would have come over
right uh or you know like achievement
like he didn't find us this way but he's
like oh you're into like you know the
body and things like that that's neat i
want to learn a little bit about the
media business can i uh learn it from
you um
have you read the book 48 laws of power
i haven't read it now but i've heard
some of them and i find it weird uh like
the summary basically the guy goes on
tik tok i don't know how he's in my
algorithm but the author robert greene
he does like one individual power at a
time on tick-tock and it always comes up
but it'll always be something so generic
that i don't know how to like it's like
very weird he'll be like laws of power
like um
don't
you don't want other people to like you
or something like that it's like
something it's like it's something like
that and i'm like okay i don't know what
this is dude why is this book so hyped
his books are like so in-depth i believe
that like in some prisons in some state
prisons throughout the country and some
states have banned the book it's it's
it's incredibly interesting too powerful
it's no for real it is it's crazy it's a
crazy book and log number 25 i used to
memorize the laws when i read it log
number 25 and i just had to google it
now i don't remember it that well log
number 25 is to always uh or
consistently recreate yourself and he
says be the master of your own image
rather than letting others define it for
you and incorporate dramatic devices
into your public gestures and actions
your power will be enhanced and your
character will seem larger than life and
with this facebook thing as well as a
lot of other things they get made fun of
for doing that but these huge
gestures
oftentimes work out well
like i did uh here's this little example
of it i had a twitter bio for the last
few months i just changed it but i know
i thought it was good 10 million in rev
or something i basically said every
twitter bio i ever saw was like the past
and i thought
okay i see the value in that like it's
good for somebody to land and know what
you're doing
but i thought what's more interesting is
like what are you trying to do now i
said how could i plant my flag just in
the
top of my profile and it was very
controversial i think a lot of people
felt
i don't know they don't tell me but i'm
i'm assuming there are there are a bunch
of people out there who probably read it
it was like this is kind of cringy or
like why is he saying this is weird and
there's some people that would deal with
what was it
all you did was said i want to make a
hun no the business will do 10 million
in revenue this year i said three things
i said four things i said
i'm trying to be in a great mood daily
yeah i'm gonna get into phenomenal shape
for the first time in my life
i'm going to make 10 million dollars by
december
and i'm going to um
i remember my last one was uh something
else but those are the three there's
something about fitness maybe the second
one is getting phenomenal shape for the
first time that and uh
something else maybe it was like i don't
know
blah blah blah family something to make
me sound good after i said i want 10
million bucks by december okay so
i put that out there and i got
i would say
five really important messages from
there of like really great connections
that came out of it from people just
being like yo like respect i respect you
for putting that there
uh i i might be able to help you with
the fitness thing or i might be able to
help you with i see you have the mood
thing what are you doing for that i want
to learn i'm like great i would love to
teach it um or
10 million bucks how are you planning to
do it how far along are you come on i
get an email from one guy he keeps
saying how far long are you getting
close your thing is inspiring me my i
set my goal too my goal is not 10
million my goal is 100 000 but i want to
make 100 000. and so like it attracts
like-minded people um and i and i i
don't even think that that was that good
of one version of this i think the the
law 25 you just said is super important
to like continuously reinvent and craft
it and like play with it um don't get
stuck in like whatever you used to say
three years ago or even three months ago
necessarily if it's no longer the the
most badass exciting fun version of you
and what you're trying to do
do you um and what does it say now you
want to build a 100 million dollar brand
or something yeah so i'm building a 100
million dollar brand and
i put that i'm investing in company
badass companies like xyz what are the
odds that um
what
so you're building a business right now
which we purposely don't talk about it
but you're building a business right now
that's in a totally separate field than
you are in now if yeah if you you being
like media uh
media different than anything i've done
before also yeah yes and
many people including me well i haven't
done this but this is something i would
have i would do
would say well what the hell just focus
on like the main thing yeah um
but do you think it's gonna work out
like
it seems like it might work out right
yeah i think it's gonna work out um i'm
pretty i'm like i think it's gonna work
out i the reason why i mean i started
with my wife so like i wanted to start a
business with her i thought we had the
idea together i thought that would be
fun i never did it normally i would go
work all day be super like you know
excited and stimulated by like all the
there she's not into tech she's not
into like the stuff i'm into so i'd come
home
and you know she'd say how's your day
and i'd be like ah it's great like you
know it's hard to much further in depth
than that right so this was a cool thing
we could do together while we uh
you know like had our first two kids and
i got two little kids now so that's why
i went into this very different thing
and also as a challenge and also we have
a couple friends that also do e-commerce
and we're doing really well with it so i
thought okay i can learn from them and
and kind of we can bounce off each other
bounce ideas off each other
would you sell it next year for like 20
or 30 million dollars
no i think it can get to i think it gets
100 and like i think we should just go
all the way that's pretty awesome and
you're enjoying it still it's not
exhausting uh it's a pain in the ass
tons of times but like you know overall
yeah like somebody like
our buddy uh suli who
um
who i talked to and kind of like look up
to his business mentor he was like he
really wanted to advise and help me with
it and i was like okay um why do you
want to do this like you know your time
on this is not gonna
not gonna
pay off like you know you have if you
just spent that same hour in your other
business or in one of these other 10
things it's just honestly it's more
valuable for you and as your friend like
i don't want you to make a decision
today that is actually a bad decision he
goes
uh like don't worry about that like he
goes i'm basically you know like i was
like you could just be having free time
he goes uh yeah i don't this is my free
time he's like i i'm only happy when i'm
in a prison of my own making
i thought it was
a badass way of saying it he's like you
know i don't want to do nothing i like
doing hard things challenging things
as long as i get to choose what the hard
and challenging thing is if it's
something i don't want to do and it's
even remotely harder challenging i'm
like a whiny baby but when it's really
hard but i chose it i i picked this
poison then uh i have so much fun like i
just wake up every day energized and i
was like wow that's a great way to know
yourself yes
well um
we can wrap up there i think what did
you uh where's ben ben what do you think
i think we covered a lot of interesting
things i like the the philosophical
wisdom yeah the end was really
great it got my wheels turning about
like what i can build kind of in public
how i can put myself out there more i
love that part i think building in
public is overrated by the way i'm gonna
do it with this ketchup thing but i
think it's overrated
you know it's better than building in
public just doing cool not talking
about it and being private
[Music]
yeah that's fair um
i'm actually i'm doing both right now i
have one thing that's in private and a
bunch of stuff that's in public and i
actually like them both um
ben what if i said what if you were
gonna put yourself out there what are
you trying to do
how would you put your plant your flag
so that you could like a magnet attract
like-minded people to you what's your
what's your version of i'm banned and
here's what i'm trying to do right now
well so i mean obviously a lot of people
know about my podcast already how to
take over the world and uh
i'm trying to make it a top 100 podcast
in the world across any country
so we're trending in the right direction
but uh i haven't really put that out in
in public yet and uh i guess now it is
so
there we go sam asked an important
question every every goal or dream
should have a time associated with it
yeah you always have to have it
you know so what what would be
otherwise you know it's a it's an
endless wish so what would be
what do you want
um
how much time is left in 2021
uh we got six weeks
yeah
uh
let's say in six weeks what's that let's
uh i got a little more than a month all
right everybody go subscribe if you
listen to this go subscribe to the how
to take over the world pocket it's
honestly an amazing podcast that's why
we've run some episodes on this feed
before uh all right we'll get you closer
um
and i think you know like if you just
said all right
i think one of the reasons people
struggle with this question is they feel
the pressure like oh this is my
purpose in life or my mission in life i
better get it right
and actually you want to do the exact
opposite you want to treat it like a kid
when you say what do you want to be when
they grow up and they say i'm going to
be a dinosaur i want to be a firefighter
i want to be a pizza man i want to be a
pizza and it's like okay
the best way to get to this statement is
actually to put zero pressure on it and
say it out loud and then say it all out
again say a different thing out loud say
like play with the ideas until something
sticks with you and hits with you and
then you say okay and then how do i
juice that if that's the dream
on level seven
what would it be on level ten what would
it be if i turned the knob all the way
broke the knob off the volume thing and
it's now at like volume 12 accidentally
what would that be of this of this
podcast like what would it be right now
if you cranked it up but by the way i
feel like we both put ourselves out
there of like putting a number to it
meanwhile sam is like i'm just gonna be
a fitness influencer but like where's
where's your number in timeline saying
um
no i have one it's to be away 185
pounds by january 15th come on okay okay
i have it written down on this piece of
paper that's not that's not an influence
that's not an influencer goal that's
just a fitness goal
that is where are you at now so you're
at 196.
sam's basically saying in the next two
months
i want to lose 11 i want to lose 11
pounds but i'm more i'm you know he's
already like you know somewhat in shape
so you know i don't know if it's
i don't feel like a body fat thing or
whatever
so now what will that attract it'll
attract other people who also want to
lose weight or have just done it right
those are the two people that are going
to reach out to sam hey me too or i just
did it you can do it too here's what i
here's what worked for me and so like
that's the power of doing this and of
saying it out loud is convincing
yourself and ben don't come at the
master when it comes to goal setting
okay
i'm the self-made i'm i'm the man i'm a
manifest cowboy baby i get it done i
just want to know when you're going to
have a hundred thousand instagram
followers sam that's all i want to know
the manifest cowboy is hilarious
my buddy uh has the best nicknames i
just discovered because he he showed up
for this thing and i was like dude you
showed up like i thought you'd be late
and i thought like you know you might
skip it today because you didn't have to
do it
and uh
our other friend was there he goes
that's why they call him mr show up and
i thought he was joking and then
literally someone called him mr i was
like is that your actual nickname mr
show up and he's like yeah he's like
that was the thing he's like he's like
anytime somebody needed like whatever
was a ride to the airport oh you know
like you need to ride home for the
airport i'll be there just give me 15
minutes i'll show up
you'd give them a throwaway invitation
to a party be like hey i'm going to this
thing um
but uh you know you won't know anybody
there and it's two hours away and like
it might not be fun he's like cool i'll
go and they're like you showed up to the
party like you don't know anyone here i
can't believe you showed up and that
became his reputation who is this guy
is this guy dom that i work with i love
this guy and he's like i thought that
nickname mr show up like i wish that was
my nickname because
i can tell you one thing mr show up is
gonna win in life because eighty percent
of life is just showing up and uh and
and if you're mister show up you're
you're acing that part of life
that's hilarious
um
i think it's gonna be a good app
yeah
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my all in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back